[ Cheers and applause ]
Hi, guys.
So, a lot of losers
on YouTube
complain that all female comics
talk about are their vaginas.
So that's what
I'm gonna do tonight.
[ Laughter ]
I have to.
Seriously, guys,
to put a long vulva short,
I have labia
that just don't quit, all right?
I know.
I thought all vaginas
looked like mine
until I was 20 years old,
and I heard Dane Cook
tell this joke.
One thing, a turn-off --
I don't like a girl
with a lot of lips.
I don't like that.
Yeah. I don't like it when it
looks like a box of cow tongues.
I don't like it
when it looks like
a high-school-play curtain,
right?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's funny.
That's what pissed me off,
because that is my vagina.
There's actually
a production of "Brigadoon"
happening down there
right now.
[ Laughter ]
Look.
Those whacky...characters.
[ Laughs ]
But after hearing that joke --
I'm serious --
I did some research on vaginas,
and --
Okay,
I watched some porn.
And I was shocked
because every porn vagina I saw
was so perfect --
just trim and tiny.
Their pussies
were like Ariana Grande
while mine
is like nachos grande.
You feel bad about yourself
when you eat it.
I jack up the price to $11
at ballparks.
A lot of similarities.
[ Laughter ]
But I wanted
what these porn stars had.
So I considered
the ultimate solution.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
Genocide.
[ Laughter ]
Just kidding.
Labiaplasty.
Have you heard of it?
It is a surgery
where a doctor basically
Benihanas your pussy
till it's small enough
to flip into your aunt's mouth.
[ Laughing ] I considered it.
I considered it,
but I couldn't do it after
getting my butthole refinished.
[ Laughter ]
It was very expensive.
So when I read
in The New York Times
that labiaplasties are becoming
increasingly popular,
especially among teens,
I was not surprised.
I had so many questions
about labiaplasty,
so I sat down
with Dr. Jennifer Berman
to learn all about
designer vaginers.
Dr. Berman, why would a woman
get labiaplasty?
Labiaplasty means removal
of excess skin in the labia.
Okay.
And if there is
a redundancy,
meaning length --
increased length --
Redundancy -- I like that,
where you're just like,
"Okay, I get it, vagina."
On and on and on and on.
And if it interferes
with sexual relations
or it's irritating
when they exercise,
you know,
those would be --
Right.
Have you noticed a trend in more
women getting labiaplasties?
I've noticed a trend
in more people talking about it,
extremely self-conscious
about their genital areas.
I'm one of those women
who have definitely started
talking about it more
because I would look at porn,
which, of course,
they're all, like,
these tiny, little God's
little whisper of a vagina,
and I would see that,
and I'd say,
"Oh, I guess that's
what everyone wants."
You hear guys --
"Oh, roast beef sandwich.
You look like --"
You just go,
"[ Laughs ]
That must be gross."
And then you're like,
"I'm disgusting."
What's driving
women's insecurity
is that we think
men think it's beautiful.
Like, I feel like this,
it's like, they stick out,
like, that much.
Well, that's --
I could pull them out
like to here probably.
That's normal.
That is?
Yeah.
It's like a little, like --
You know like a little dog's
soft little tongue peeking out?
It's almost like --
All right, I get it.
All right, so,
there's a little bit
of what we call "labial show,"
which
is what you're describing.
Ooh! I --
That's gonna be
my Broadway play.
Labial Show.
You did it.
You named it for me.
So, there's sexual sensations
that are in that area.
It also adds a little bit
of length to the vagina,
so it kind of grabs
along the outside,
so there's a functional purpose
to the labia.
"Don't let go, dick."
[ Laughs ]
It's almost like they're --
a cliffhanger.
Yeah.
So, what are
some of the drawbacks
of getting labiaplasty?
I've seen some majorly botched
labiaplasties.
Really?
Yes.
Changing it, mutilating it,
even, to some degree.
So you shouldn't just get it
willy-nilly.
You certainly shouldn't do it
just for cosmetic reasons.
I'm leaving
this conversation feeling, like,
I love it, and I just
want to spread the love.
Can I get a hug?
[ Laughs ]
Come here.
I'm so glad
you're so comfortable.
I love you.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, look.
If you're labes are causing you
actual physical pain,
do what you need to do,
absolutely.
But if they're not,
let sleeping lips lie.
Unless you're posing for
some vagina of the month
calendar, I guess,
which even then, like, wouldn't
you want yours to stand out?
Like, let's make this
a September to remember.
[ Laughter ]
And why risk
losing sexual sensation
just to look "acceptable"
for a
guy whose dick
can barely tell the difference
beautiful a pussy and
a thermos of warm SpaghettiOs?
[ Laughter ]
And if someone is shitty enough
to make fun of your labia,
surgery is not gonna help
because the problem
is not with your pussy.
It's with the pussy you're
letting inside your pussy,
so try cutting that off first.
In the meantime,
let's all embrace who we are,
all right?
I have big naturals,
and I'm proud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanks, guys.
We'll be right back.
Anyone else?
Anyone else got big --
You do? Oh, yeah.